il est grand temps de retrouver la
sélection livre du jour avec tiphaine et
aujourd'hui on célèbre un anniversaire
si je vous dit soraya eventhia lecerf et
la vigne le lion et le moucheron la
colombe et la fourmi ou je sais pas moi
le lièvre et la tortue la cigale et la
formule corbeau et le renard la fontaine
louis jean de la fontaine on est
d'accord on est d'accord on est d'accord
aussi aux tiefensee fort et oui
évidemment et vous en avez cité
certaines qui ne sont pas très connus
puisqu'il faut rappeler que jean de la
fontaine a écrit environ 240 fable alors
si j'ai décidé de vous en parler
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on célèbre le
400e anniversaire de sa naissance en
1621 et je trouve ça assez dommage
finalement qu'on en parle uniquement à
l'école et je crois que je ne suis pas
la seule puisque le célèbre écrivain
alexandre jardin a décidé de mettre les
fables de la fontaine hauteur des
enfants de 3 4 ans avec ce livre
les fables de la fontaine dynamite est
illustré par fred muletiers est publié
aux éditions gautier languereau le
principe est simple
il a écrit des petites histoires très
accessible dans le français actuel qui
reprennent lé moral des fables de la
fontaine les plus connus alors ça donne
par exemple la course folle qui reprend
le lièvre et la tortue ou je ne sais pas
par exemple vous avez celle ci une bonne
blague qui reprend et bien la cigogne et
le renard alors c'est très intelligent
de faire savent puisque les morales
servent dans la vie quotidienne
et puis au début et bien il y a toujours
la fable original ce qui permettra aux
parents de lire et bien cette jolie
lampe du xviie siècle à leur enfant
parfait parfait vous avez aussi un autre
ouvrage à nous proposer un roman à cette
fois qui lui aussi s'inspire finalement
du grand siècle tiffen oui tout à fait
ça s'appelle le singe est l'épouvantail
c'est un hommage à la fois à la fontaine
et aux musiciens du xviie siècle
alors les critiques histoire panon a été
écrite par pierre sens et elle raconté
l'histoire d'un sa page ou deux mais
fricandeau qui a décidé par tous les
moyens d'intégrer la cour de la duchesse
frangipane
alors pour cela il est conseillé par un
épouvantail qui connaît par coeur les
fables de la fontaine alors dit comme ça
ça a l'air complètement farfelu et ça
l'est un peu et ça plaira beaucoup aux
enfants de 7 8 ans puisque à de
multiples rebondissements
alors en plus l'éditeur a décidé de
mettre en musique cette histoire est
notamment de faire une version chantée
des fables avec et bien des musiciens
baroques et les petits chanteurs de la
maîtrise de la cathédrale de metz c'est
vraiment très très réjouissant ça
permettra faire découvrir à la fois la
fontaine et la musique du xviie et
xviiie siècles
pour terminer on a un bon plan pour les
ados pour les adultes que nous sommes
aussi vous avez déniché finalement un
ouvrage qui est loin du format de poche
comme cet ouvrage que j'ai là qui forme
à la meca rien à voir il parle de
voyance et de numérologie en découvrir
quelques extraits d'ici quelques
secondes avec mes deux invités qui sont
là vous avez d'initier un ouvrage donc
loin du format de poche que l'on trouve
tout cette fois ci dans sa bibliothèque
un temps où il pourrait finalement
facilement aller dans la bibliothèque
oui alors celui-ci c'est un joyau ans
est un joyau des éditions hazan qui
publie en général des beaux livres et là
c'est vraiment un livre magnifique c'est
la rencontre du peintre russe marc
chagall avec les fables de la fontaine
alors c'était l'idée du célèbre marchand
d'art ambroise vollard en 1927 il a
proposé sa à marc chagall et lui a dit
est-ce que vous accepteriez d'illustrer
les fables de la fontaine et marc
chagall qui étaient installés en france
a adoré cette idée et a proposé une
centaine de gouache et d'eaux fortes
pour illustrer ce livre alors il y en a
et de toutes les couleurs c'est vraiment
magnifique sais pas si vous voyez est en
fait il les a composées et peintes
pendant que sa femme bella lui lisait
les fables de la fontaine
alors on retrouvait bien les paysages
français qu'il aimait mais aussi et bien
l'inspiration russe
et puis l'imaginaire de chagall alors il
faut savoir pour la petite histoire que
les français de l'époque ont trouvé ça
choquant qu'on propose un peintre russe
d'illustrer le grand fabuliste de
l'époque mais vole à retrouver ça
normal finalement puisque à la fois la
fontaine et chagall avait l'amour de
lorient puisque la fontaine je le
rappelle c'est inspiré du fabuliste grec
esope mais aussi des fables des fables
indienne du punch à tentera donc voilà
je vous le conseille vraiment c'est un
magnifique livre pour les ados et les
adultes
et puis à l'heure où les musées sont
fermés bien ça permet de voir quelques
oeuvres d'art parfait la fontaine vu par
chagall moi j'aime bien la sélection
livre on retrouve évidemment sur les
réseaux sociaux et en replay sur france
3 point fr si ça ne marche pas au fait
appel une célèbre phrase de jean de la
fontaine qui dit patience et longueur de
temps font plus que force ni que rage
c'est qu'on est en train de mettre les
les câbles et que et que voilà échos la
chronique arrive en ligne très très
bientôt
juste avant de se quitter tiphaine vous
avez déjà fait appel à une voyante ou à
une numérologue en votre nom
non j'avoue que non mais peut-être parce
que je n'en ai pas rencontrés le 12